Aww yeah, it's time to have some fun
learning English with Ariana Grande.
So, in this lesson we're going to first
learn with Ariana's hit song "Seven Rings".
Following that, we will teach you with a
short and humorous interview with Ariana.
So every single week we make fun lessons
so that you can understand fast speaking
natives, just like Ariana Grande, without
getting lost, without missing the jokes,
and without subtitles.
Just like Roshan who said that after
just two weeks of watching our videos
he already knows improvement in his
listening and your English is going to
improve a ton too. All you have to do is
hit that subscribe button and the bell
down below,
so you don't miss any of our new lessons.
Hey, wouldn't you like to be able to understand
natives like Ariana Grande?
well then our Fluent with Friends course
is perfect for you.
Every week for  48 weeks you will get a lesson following
along with the first two seasons of the
series Friends. Plus, you get 20 plus page
PDF power lessons, vocabulary
memorization software, access to our
Fluency Circle global community and so
much more.
What are you waiting for?
You can try for free right now with our
three-part master class. All you have to
do is click up here or down in the
description below
to learn more and sign up for that.
Hey, if you're enjoying this lesson with
Ariana Grande, then I bet you're going to
love all of the lessons in this playlist
with celebrities.
You can check that out after you finish this video.
All right, I hope you had a lot of fun
learning English with Ariana Grande today.
There's more where that came from.
The first step is to hit that subscribe
button so you don't miss any of our new
lessons, and then the next step would be
to watch another one of our videos so
you can improve your fluency right now.
And now, it's time to go beyond the
classroom and live your English! Awww yeah!